alors ma maison on commence par la
chambre à coucher parce que j'ai mon
matelas et alors là j'ai deux du vélo un
qui fait dix-huit -18° de là j'ai ma
salle de bain donc j'ai des lingettes
gels vidéo franchement là j'me large
fait pas semblant juste au dessus de la
salle de bain j'ai le bureau il ya mes
câblage pour le rechargement via une
radio il ya une lampe frontale
le premier danger de la russe elise
hommes parce que du moment on s'isole on
mai puis avec les autres une personne
peut voir ce qui nous arrive ou ou si on
meurt ou aussi on est malade c'est très
simple internet c'est même séché sdf
assis sur un banc j'ai toute la planète
avec moi concrètement j'ai un abonnement
qui me coûte aller avec mes dépassements
10 euros par mois et l'utilité comme
assez l'information les réseaux sociaux
tout simplement pour n'importe quels
renseignements chercher une adresse
chercher des horaires d'ouverture une
administration
[Musique]
oui
dans la rue on a un principe c'est que
nous on fait pas de hiérarchie dans la
misère
un mec qui qui est à la rue a besoin d'
aide un sans abri a besoin des d'après
on va pas chercher à savoir si les
boliviens
si les sud africains si les allemands ou
ou si les suisses à la base solide et la
logique de l'action sociale en ce moment
c'est pas du tout ça c'est la police
table sur les migrants l'or
on enlève leur matériel leur couverture
leurs tentes
alors qu'on annonce d'un autre côté un
plan grand froid et d'un autre côté on
les gens et 10 c'est dégueulasse il ya
un noir qu'à ta place dans un foyer il
ya un arabe que ta place dans un foyer
alors que christian tu es un français
tout ça c'est des conneries il devrait y
avoir personne dehors c'est tout migrant
pas migrants français par français on
s'en fout
[Musique]